Salut à tous
Voici une petite vidéo 360°
Alors voila, je vous préviens tout de suite si vous êtes sur ordinateur vous pouvez vous déplacer avec les flèches.
Normalement vous verrez des flèches sur Youtube
Si vous êtes sur Smartphone vous pourrez vous déplacer en orientant l'écran de votre téléphone.
Et donc vous pouvez regarder tout autour de vous
Là on est au sud de la Californie, le soleil est caché derrière ces arbres,
Mais il va apparaitre dans quelques instants le temps que j'avance
Donc voilà, je voulais essayer un petit peu la vidéo 360°
avant de faire des vidéos un peu plus
un peu plus sérieuses peut-être
enfin des vrais sketchs et tout.
Donc voilà, super beau (le paysage)
Magnifique
Et donc je me suis dit ...
En fait, je me suis posé la question: Pourquoi y'a 360°dans un cercle, quoi ? D'où ça sort ?
Et en fait y'a différentes théories
On sait pas trop. La première théorie elle est
- astronomique. En fait, si tu regardes
- l'ancien calendrier perse,
l'ancien calendrier des babyloniens,
y'avait 360 jours dans l'année.
C'est à dire qu'en gros, une année, tu vois, c'est un tour.
Alors suivant les croyances on pouvait croire que c'était un tour du Soleil
-autour de la Terre.
Maintenant, on sait que c'est la Terre autour du Soleil.
Mais en gros c'est un tour.
Et donc bah, ça fait 360 parties les journées pour faire ce tour.
Donc tout simplement, tu vois de manière triviale, 360° pourquoi pas ?
C'est une des explications.
L'autre théorie qu'on a c'est sur le système babylonien.
En fait ... Hi !
Je me suis pris un gros vent.
En même temps j'ai pas trop osé, enfin bon bref.
Regardez là, on voit la mer là bas.
Le système babylonien, en gros l'idée c'est ... on va faire un cercle... alors ...
La géométrie babylonienne était vachement basée sur les cordes.
C'était pas la seule hein. Mais elle était basée sur les cordes ...
Et en gros, si on fait un cercle ... donc on va faire un cercle ...
Je vais juste déplier ce trépied.
Voilà
Donc si je fais un cercle avec ça comme rayon
Donc c'est-à-dire en gros ... un cercle qui fait tout ça.
Et bien, ce rayon je peux le caler, en gros, six fois dans mon cercle.
Je peux le caler six fois, donc je peux diviser mon cercle en six parties simplement.
Et, le truc c'est que les babyloniens, eux, ils n'avaient pas un système décimal comme nous.
Donc ... 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 ...
Et ensuite, 11, 12, 13 etc ....
Eux, ils avaient un système sexagésimal.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils étaient par paquets de soixante, en fait.
Alors ... en gros ... au niveau de comment ils faisaient pour compter ...
Il se pourrait... en fait je vais reposer ce truc là ... ( le trépied )
Les gens qui habitent ici, ils sont bien ... ILS SONT BIEN.
Alors voilà, en gros... Avec une main, ils faisaient 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 ... etc ...
Pour arriver jusqu'à 12.
Et avec l'autre main, ils comptaient les paquets de douze.
Après, y'a différentes théories. Y'en a qui disent que ça faisait: 1, 2, 3 ... 4, 5, 6 ... 7, 8, 9 ...
Tu vois, suivant les parties de ton doigt. Parce que les phalanges et tout ... bref.
Et donc, si tu divises chaque paquet par soixante
Et bien, ça fait six fois soixante, ça fait 360°.
Et donc, ça se tient complètement qu'ils aient découpé le cercle de cette façon.
Alors, en plus de ça, 360 c'est un nombre qui peut être divisé par plein de trucs.
Puisqu'il peut être divisé par ... 1 évidemment...
Mais (aussi) 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 8, 9, 10.
Il peut être divisé par plein de choses.
C'est même un nombre abondant. Donc je vous mettrais ce que c'est dans la description.
Et en fait, il est possible que ce soit, un petit peu, un mélange de toutes ces théories là.
Donc, concordance de tout ça...
Ce qui fait que 360, c'est juste que ça tombe très très bien...
Mais donc voilà, ça nous vient de nos amis les babyloniens.
Regardez moi ça ! Regardez ... J'espère que vous n'êtes pas en train de me regarder. Que vous êtes plutôt en train de regarder ce paysage fantastique.
Voilà
Voilà.
Je voulais juste vous souhaiter une très bonne année avec ce paysage .
J'espère que ... je vous souhaite beaucoup de bonheur, santé...
L'amour, la réussite, tout ça.
Et on se retrouve très bientôt.
On se retrouve pas ce jeudi mais celui d'après. Jeudi prochain.
Pour une nouvelle vidéo sur la chaîne.
Donc une vidéo classique cette fois. Ça sera un Coup de Phil.
Donc voilà les amis !
Je vous fais de gros bisous.
Ciao !
Je vous envoie du love et de la peace.
Et tchequez la description pour peut-être des infos ou me suivre ... des choses comme ça.
[chuchote] Voilà, on se quitte avec ce magnifique couché de soleil.
Pfiou ! Amazing.
Voilà.
[chantonne] Il est beau le soleil...
Regardez là. Je vous laisse un petit peu de temps pour pouvoir regardez autour de vous.
C'est stylé nan ? Ça donne pas trop envie de ... [souffle]
Calme-toi Cyrius.
Calme-toi.
Tant que j'y suis, je continue.